after his parents divorce
sixteen-year-old kazuo and his mother
moved to her hometown nagano kazuo used
to live here when he was in kindergarten
so he is confident he will settle right
back in on his first day at school he is
introduced to the class suddenly a girl
gets up recognizing him from the time
they were in kindergarten her name is
kazumi and she used to be best friends
with kazuo a long time ago she even
reveals that he wetted his bed and had
to wear her underwear one time casual
realizes that's where the fetish came
from he remembers the incident but
pretends to be oblivious after class he
goes to kazumi asking her to stop
telling everyone about these
embarrassing stories of the past
kazumi's boyfriend hiroshi interrupts
them and is jealous of their friendship
after school kazumi follows kazuo as he
tries his best to get rid of her she
reminds him of his favorite noodle he
used to have at her mother's noodle shop
when he says he doesn't remember she
brings him home her family is delighted
to see him after so long but kazuo feels
uncomfortable because he hardly
remembers them while kazumi's mother
cooks the noodles she is asked to show
kazuo the shabi shira spring the water
used to make the noodles comes from the
spring which is the secret ingredient
the two walk for a few minutes before
reaching the place they have to take
different paths especially meant for two
genders to get to the spring kazumi
picks up a dipper so casual can taste
the water they stand on either side of
the spring which causes them to struggle
for the dipper and fall into it when
they come outside they have miraculously
changed their bodies with each other
kazuo doesn't realize this and makes his
way home without saying anything that's
impossible he takes off the wet clothes
and the first thing he notices is that
he is wearing a skirt confused he looks
into the mirror and sees kasamy instead
of himself it doesn't take him long to
register that he has changed bodies with
her he runs outside to tell his mother
who thinks he is a perverted girl trying
to seduce her son she makes him wear a
jacket before kicking him out after that
kazuo goes to kazumi's home and finds
her crying hysterically her family is
also just as confused as everyone else
they think the kids hit their heads
while on their way to the spring and are
not in their right minds moreover since
kazumi is not wearing enough clothes
they assume kazuo did something to her
before their anger escalates kazuo runs
away with kazumi on his bicycle kazumi's
biggest concern is kazuo touching her
breasts but kazuo argues that he has no
interest in her liar he brings her to
his home asking her to act like a man as
much as possible they decide to stay in
each other's places until they find a
way to get back into their respective
bodies at first kazuo experiences the
difference in gender roles when he is
made to serve dinner to everyone in his
family moreover he learns that he has to
eat quickly because if not the family
will devour everything meanwhile kazumi
is doing just fine at kazuo's home she
cooks for his mother surprising her with
a delicious meal the mother goes on a
rant about an indecent girl like kazumi
for barging into their home unaware that
her son is the same indecent girl kazumi
doesn't know about kazuo's parents
divorce so she asks questions like when
will his dad return home kazuo's mother
thinks it is a joke and asks him to be
more compassionate towards her she also
discovers that casual broke up with his
long-term girlfriend akemi before moving
here a while later kazuo calls kazumi
asking her to keep his phone strap
safely it was a gift from his father and
is close to his heart kazumi on the
other hand is having problems of her own
she is shocked by how his genitals
changed when she tried to take a shower
kazuo orders her to stop looking at his
body and ends the call the following
morning kazuo wakes up in kazumi's room
and remembers what happened yesterday
then he checks himself in the mirror and
to his distress sleeping has not turned
him back to normal kazumi breaks in
through the window with kazuo's school
uniform that he left at his home
yesterday she also teaches him how to
wear a bra but just then her mother
interrupts them she assumes the worst
and calls the entire family into the
room as they yell at their daughter
kazuo and kazumi trick them and run away
to school they promised to do their best
as each other before walking in during
music class kazumi is asked to play the
piano because kazuo was well known as a
talented pianist in his former school
when she is in the front she gets a
panic attack and runs to the rooftop
casual follows her while being followed
by the teacher they meet each other on
the roof where the teacher inquires
about what is going on kazumi panics
again and accidentally knocks the
teacher out hiroshi finds kazuo and
kazumi together and suspects something
is going on between them boy if only he
knew after school the two sit by the
river and discuss their situation kazumi
touches kazuo's body reminiscing about
her older self but to a man walking past
them it looks like they are doing
something else he tries to join them in
the fun and holds kazuo's hand to defend
himself kazuo kicks him in the nuts and
runs away with kazumi in the following
scene both kazuo kazumi and their
mothers are called to an older
gentleman's home he is the father of the
guy they beat up earlier he wants to
press charges against kazumi but has to
consider otherwise after discovering his
son wanted to kidnap the girl then kazuo
and kazumi are together when kazuo gets
a text from hiroshi he is jealous of
their growing relationship and is ready
to break up if that is what kazumi
prefers kazumi replies that she loves
him and just asks him to give her some
space at home kazumi's mother notices
that her daughter is acting more strange
day by day she lays down like a man
speaks like one and has forgotten how to
cook hence kazumi's older brother is
called from tokyo to take care of her
kazuo has been more sensitive than
normal because his period is near
moreover both kazuo and kazumi are
forbidden to meet each other outside
school after what happened yesterday he
panics since he has no clue what must be
done when he gets his period he also
feels awfully weak but passes it as a
symptom the next day their class is
going on a trip to a hot spring
throughout the bus ride casual continues
puking worrying everyone then while
changing into a swimsuit his nose starts
to bleed at the same time kazumi meets
hiroshi and asks him to come aside
before she can tell him the truth he
asks her if she is kazumi it turns out
that he had been observing them for the
past few days and has come to this
conclusion kazumi affirms and apologizes
for not telling him sooner hiroshi says
that he still loves her because he is in
love with her soul not her body however
kazumi doesn't feel the same for him on
the first day after the trip kazuo
doesn't come to school kazumi is worried
but her mother doesn't let her see kazuo
hence hiroshi goes over to make sure he
is fine it turns out that kazuo has had
sharp body pain and has been vomiting
since the morning he goes to the doctors
the next day and they find out that he
suffers from an incurable disease and
has only two months to live kazumi's
parents are shocked and in pain the
doctor promises to do whatever he can to
ensure kazuo's last days are painless
but he cannot help the family other than
that hiroshi finds out about this and
comes to tell kazumi she is just as
shocked as everyone else because
caswell's death could mean a lot of
different things she is worried for him
and for herself because her body could
go away forever when she goes to visit
him she is initially stopped by her
mother the woman blames her for casual's
condition because he has been acting
strangely after her arrival the doctor
convinces her that they should not keep
a bedridden girl from meeting her friend
kazumi meets kazuo and feels responsible
for his illness since her body has the
disease it is almost as if he is dying
because of her kazuwo assures her that
even if that were the case he would be
happy to die in her place when kazumi
returns home that day she convinces
kazuo's mother to go visit him she
agrees and tells her about akemi akemi
is to be kazuo's girlfriend and is
coming to visit him in a few days kazumi
emails akemi at night and tells her
everything about the situation in the
following scene kazumi and hiroshi
welcome akemi to the city she has known
kazuo for years and can tell that kazumi
is not him later she and kazuo's mother
go to visit him kazuo shares an
emotional conversation with them making
the mother feel like she is talking to
her own child a few days later akemi
hiroshi kazuo and kazumi are together
when kazuo says he wants to go somewhere
far away the adults would not allow him
so they decide to sneak out at night the
plan works and they reach the mountains
by the morning akami and hiroshi know
that the other two want to spend time
together so they ask them to go ahead
after that the two are spotted by a
group of performers they join the group
and decide to stay with them for the
night kazumi has a hard time falling
asleep so she cuddles with kazuo and
inquires if they can take their
relationship a step further kazuo says
he wants to make love to her but only as
a guy kazumi understands and hugs him
instead she also takes his top off and
says goodbye to her body for the last
time the next morning kazumi hears two
men talking about her and kazuo they are
planning to do something to get rid of
the couple instead of being a burden on
them she and kazuo leave a while later
kazumi wants to go home now but kazuo
says that is the last place he wants to
visit then they make their way to the
sabhishira spring where it all began
unlike the last time they do not take
the separate gender gates since they are
both male and female they stand on the
edge of the spring drinking from a
dipper suddenly they slip and fall into
the water for the second time they
somehow manage to get outside but soon
realize that they have changed back into
their respective bodies kazumi is over
the moon that kazuo doesn't have to die
in her place but kazuo cannot help but
feel sad she will go away and he will
have to continue living without her they
hug each other for a long time before
kazumi says she is happy to die for him
then they go to a cliff and watch the
sunset together cut to a few months
later kazumi is no more and the world
has moved on without her casual comes to
her home often to meet her family
because of all the time he spent with
them he feels like he is a part of the
family one afternoon he arrives and
finds kazumi's grandfather making
noodles he offers to help but unlike the
traditional way of kneading he steps on
the dough this reminds the family of
kazumi and they cannot help but shed
tears it turns out that kazuo has come
to say goodbye because he is moving to a
different city for college we also find
out that akemi and hiroshi are now
dating each other before leaving the
city kazuo visits kazumi's grave and
wishes her goodbye what he doesn't know
is that her spirit is watching him with
a smile on her face glad that he is
moving on with his life on his way out
kazuo passes hiroshi who has also come
to pay respect the movie ends with a
message that says a person's lifespan is
limited but a story lasts forever
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching oh my god that was sad